[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to episode
number 114 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform podcast.
I'm Mark Mandel and I'm here
with my colleague, Melanie
Warrick.
How are we doing this
fine morning, Melanie?
MELANIE WARRICK: Great, Mark.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm
doing very well.
Glad to be back in the
recording studio with you today.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes, it is
good to be back here as well.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
Talking is hard.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
today, we are going to be--
on this very special
day, we are going
to be actually talking with
Timnit and Margaret, who
are coming from Microsoft
and Google, respectively,
working in machine
learning and AI research.
And they're also specifically
here to talk to us
about machine learning
bias and fairness.
And they do a lot of
research around that,
which we had a great time
talking to them about.
So I'm looking forward
to that interview.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, amazing.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
unfortunately, we
didn't have enough time for it.
But before we get
to that, we always
do the cool things of the week.
And we also have our question
at the end of the podcast, which
is basically a chat between Mark
and a mutual friend of ours,
KF.
The question is
pretty much that,
is there a GCP service
that's basically
cloud identity aware proxy
except for a static site
that you host via cloud storage?
So we'll get into that at
the end of the podcast.
All right, Mark, what's a
cool thing of the week that's
on your mind?
MARK MANDEL: Cool
things of the week--
so I'm going to go to
the community first,
rather than one
of our blog posts.
There is a really
cool media blog
post talking about GPS
cellular asset tracking
using Google Cloud, IoT Core,
Firestore, and Mongoose OS.
It is written by
someone whose name
is, I am unfortunately going to
completely and utterly butcher.
I'm going to go with
Alvaro Viebrantz.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Sounds good to me.
MARK MANDEL: Seems close enough?
It's a really great article that
goes into great technical depth
about how they put all the
pieces together, shows off
a lot of code on how,
basically, they get information
from the assets themselves,
so the mobile devices,
into IoT Core, which then takes
things into Pub/Sub, which then
puts things in Cloud Functions,
which then goes into Cloud
Firestore, which then goes into
a web app based on Firebase
Hosting.
It's a really great read.
You should probably check
that out if any of that
sounds particularly
interesting to you.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
And they provide
a tutorial on how
to do this as well,
which is really awesome.
So definitely check that out.
MARK MANDEL: What do you got?
MELANIE WARRICK:
All right, I have
that there are GPUs now
involved with Kubernetes engine.
So basically, GPUs
in Kubernetes engine
is now available in beta.
And when you are spinning
up anything with Kubernetes
engine, you can just set up
what kind of GPUs you need,
type, number, and
you're good to go.
MARK MANDEL: Sweet.
Finally, I know there are a lot
of Java programmers out there
and Spring is a very
popular framework.
So we are actually
announcing Spring Cloud GCP,
integrating your favorite Java
framework with Google Cloud.
So if you're using
Spring and you
want to use a product like, say,
Cloud SQL, or Cloud Pub/Sub,
or Cloud Storage, or Stackdriver
Trace, or the Runtime
Configuration API, there's
direct integrations
with Spring frameworks such as
their JDBC framework, Spring
Resources, Cloud Sleuth,
those sort of things,
that are available.
If you want to get
started, there's
links to code samples, reference
documentation, the GCP project
page, as well as having
Spring Cloud Code Labs-
wow, that's hard to
say-- that you can also
go to and have a play with.
So if Spring is your thing--
oh, that was fun--
go check that out.
MELANIE WARRICK:
It's coming out.
All right, well,
I think it's time
to go talk with
Timnit and Margaret.
So let's do that.
This week's podcast we're
excited to have Timnit Gebru
and Margaret Mitchell join us
to talk about machine learning
fairness.
They both have experience
and research backgrounds,
especially around machine
learning, cognitive sciences,
computer vision,
language processing.
I'm definitely excited to
have them here because they've
been doing some work
around bias and fairness
in the machine
learning and AI space
that I think will be very
interesting to hear about.
So welcome.
TIMNIT GEBRU: Thanks.
Thanks for having us.
MARGARET MITCHELL:
MELANIE WARRICK:
So, Timnit, can you
give us a little
more information
about your background?
TIMNIT GEBRU: Sure, I have a
very roundabout way of arriving
at where I am right now.
I studied electrical
engineering at Stanford.
And well, I'm originally
from Ethiopia.
I was a refugee here.
I came to the the
States when I was 16.
And so then I went
to Stanford to study
electrical engineering.
And I did analog circuit
design, like hardware.
And I did that for my--
and then I worked
at Apple doing that,
designing circuits
and things like this.
And then I got a master's.
And then somehow I was
working in something
called device physics,
which is, then, even
more of analog circuit design.
And somehow I started getting
interested in image processing.
And then that became
computer vision.
And then I just kind of
switched my entire direction
to do computer vision in my PhD.
And then towards the end of
when I was working on computer
vision, I was very, very
worried about the lack
of diversity in that
entire field and just
in AI in general.
Like, every time I
went to a conference,
I would not see women.
But also I would see very,
very few black people.
And then towards
the end of my PhD,
I also read this
ProPublica article
about software that's predicting
crime recidivism rates.
So that started to worry me.
And then I decided I wanted
to spend a little bit of time
trying to understand the
societal impacts of AI
and some work of people who were
working on fairness and things
like this, like Meg has worked
on it way longer than me.
So then I joined Microsoft
Research in New York,
in the FATE group.
So FATE stands for Fairness,
Accountability, Transparency,
and Ethics.
So right now I'm doing
a post doc there.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thanks.
That's great.
And Margaret, your background--
I know you're at
Google, but you've also
had a background with Microsoft.
MARGARET MITCHELL: Yeah, so I
did my PhD in computer science,
focusing on natural
language processing.
And then I eventually
joined MSR as a researcher
there in the natural
language processing
group under Bill
Dolon and worked a lot
on language generation,
which is producing
linguistic descriptions
about the real world.
My work was generally
grounded in images.
So I worked on that while
at Microsoft Research.
And I was really noticing and
focusing on some of the things
that my systems were
starting to generate.
As we moved into deep
learning, the language
that was being generated seemed
more and more human like.
And within that
human likeness there
were more and more things
that were alarming me.
And so I started focusing
more and more directly
on a couple of things.
One is, how can we take the
technology we're working on
and put it forward for positive,
ethical use cases, long term?
And that was really focusing
on things like accessibility.
As well as, how can we do
things like mitigate bias
or address problematic
human biases and stereotypes
in the data we're training
on so that eventually we
don't propagate or
amplify the biases?
There was an opportunity for me
to really focus on the ethics
part of this at Google.
And so after three years
I left Microsoft Research
and then joined Google to work
directly on fairness and ethics
in machine learning.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
I know when I met
both of you, you
were co-hosting or
co-running an AI ethics group
that was made up of people
from all different groups,
all different companies,
education backgrounds.
And it was a great
session in terms
of just talking about some of
the issues, the broader issues.
I think the main
question I want to ask
is, to just help our
listeners starting out,
you've touched on
it, but can you
give us how to think
about what is ML fairness?
MARGARET MITCHELL: That's
a really big question.
So when we talk
about ML fairness,
we're often talking about
something like prejudice
or stereotypes
that are propagated
by algorithmic systems
and specifically
machine learning systems.
There's a lot of ways to
talk about what fairness is.
And bias comes in
and then bias can
mean a few different
things, some of it
mathematical, some of it social.
Basically the fairness world
kind of encompasses a lot
of the things that have
to do with the diversity
and inclusion in the
outputs of our systems
and looking at
whether or not there
is disproportional
negative effects
or disproportional
inaccuracies on some subgroups
corresponding to different
kinds of social groups
like race, gender, age.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thanks.
And in terms of the work
that you've both done,
I know you've talked
about the groups
that you've been involved in.
Can you tell us a little bit
more about what Google's doing
and what Microsoft is doing in
these spaces with ML fairness?
TIMNIT GEBRU: I
can talk about what
Microsoft is doing specifically,
especially my group.
So one of the reasons
I joined FATE--
it's a newly created
group-- is because it's
an interdisciplinary group.
So I really believe that you
can't address this problem
by just talking to other
machine learning people.
MARGARET MITCHELL: Yeah.
TIMNIT GEBRU: Or by just
talking to other lawyers,
because for example,
there are some laws--
equal employment opportunity
laws, for example--
that I don't think are
being applied to algorithms,
like hiring algorithms,
that could have biased
outputs or things like this.
So I think there are
people like Kate Crawford.
Hanna Wallach does
machine learning but also
computational social science.
Jenn Wortman Vaughan,
and there's also
other people who work
with us peripherally
like Glenn, who is a very
well-known economist.
And so what we do
is, we not only try
to understand the
societal impacts
but also then work on
some technical machine
learning solutions.
So personally, what I've
been very focused on,
even though what
I like to do most
is technical work, computer
vision or purely machine
learning, this year
I've been more focused
on trying to uncover some biases
that exist in commercial APIs,
for example, that are
being sold to people.
And then trying to
figure out how to
have a standardized way
of providing some sort
of information for people.
So for example, from
my hardware background
I know that any little
component that you use, like
from the cheapest
resistor to something
as complicated as a CPU or
something like this, always
comes with something
called a data sheet, right?
And so for me, I'm
trying to evangelize
this idea of a datasheet or
pre-trained models, APIs,
and data sets, and
trying to understand
what that would look like,
what the pitfalls are,
or if we had a datasheet
for this type of process
what it would look like.
And trying to talk to other
product groups as well,
trying to work with them
to see what it would look
like for them, if
it's useful for them
to have this idea,
et cetera, et cetera.
So in addition to, I
guess, the technical work,
I'm personally more focused
on trying to understand policy
and what kinds of
standardizations we could have
and things like this.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
MARGARET MITCHELL: So at
Google, one of the things
that really, really appealed
to me was the ability to work
across the organization.
And so part of my
job now involves
talking to people
on who's working
on mobile devices,
Assistant, Cloud,
all these different kinds
of products and services
that Google is offering.
And talking to them
at the level of code,
at the level of data--
like what's going on that
might be amplifying
different kinds of biases?
And so we're starting to
put out some stuff publicly,
specifically focused
on machine learning
code that can help mitigate
different kinds of biases.
We're working incredibly
hard internally
across a variety of
different dimensions,
from what the UX
experience should
be like when you have
some sort of bias issue
to what kind of input we
want from different kinds
of sources.
Like Timnit says, including
people from policy,
including people
who have focused
on ethics philosophically,
really trying
to dig into this cross
disciplinary effort
across Google as a whole.
So it's been a really
nice chance for me
to try and make
change from within,
working directly
with products that I
know are touching millions
or billions of people.
And really walking through, how
can we make this really work
for everyone?
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
It's nice that there's both the
internal but also, like Timnit,
you're saying, you know, working
this cross-disciplinary way
of looking at how to think about
this on a broader scale, too.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Timnit, you touched
on this briefly.
I'm happy to let you all talk.
You know way more
about this than I do.
But Timnit, you touched
on this briefly about,
you're talking about sort of
biases in hiring practices.
I wonder if you could expand on
maybe some common or possibly
some not well known biases
that ML can introduce?
Or what, basically,
are some examples,
especially for those people
who aren't necessarily
as familiar with the space.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And I know you've
got a research paper that
was out around demographics,
especially looking at cars.
So I know that's one that
might probably be on mind.
TIMNIT GEBRU: So let
me answer your question
in a particular way, to bring in
something I always want to talk
about, which is diversity.
So this is why I think
diversity is important.
It's basically almost like
having domain knowledge.
So for example, when--
I guess this is a well
known example, which
is the crime recidivism rates
that I was talking about.
So there was this
ProPublica article
that talked about how this
company was using machine
learning to predict someone's
likelihood of committing
a crime again, right?
So when I read this
article I was immediately
absolutely horrified
because I just
knew that there was absolutely
no way that this software would
not be biased.
The reason is that I've been
a black woman all my life
and I live in the US.
And I know all sorts of things
that happened to my friends.
I know all sorts of statistics
for the likelihood of being
caught by police if
you commit a crime
as a black person versus not,
in certain neighborhoods,
et cetera.
So all of these things
just came to my brain
when I was reading
about this article.
And I immediately, even
though I have never
worked in fairness
before and I didn't even
think before that
about this concept
of algorithmic fairness,
that article for me
was very scary because I
had this domain knowledge
that this bias exists,
because of my background
and because of the types of
things I've been reading about.
So I guess my
point is that there
are many such things where--
so one thing I
learned, for example,
is that speech recognition
does not work well
for younger people,
but also people
who have hearing impairments
or things like this.
And I'm not in that community,
so it's more difficult for me
to know about these biases.
But someone who has
that type of domain
knowledge-- it's
important for me
to interface with
someone that has
that type of domain
knowledge in order
to know about these biases.
So for me this issue of bias
and diversity go hand in hand.
And sometimes I get
frustrated if we only
talk about the technical
aspects because I just
feel like they go hand in hand.
MARGARET MITCHELL: Timnit,
I really hear you on that.
And one thing that I
think has really struck me
as I've worked on fairness and
I've worked with others on it
is that it's actually
really difficult
to work on machine learning
models where you're
recognizing, for example, that
this only works for pale males,
or this only works
for men and not women,
and not see the same kind of
patterns in your everyday work
life.
I mean, ideally these
are two separate worlds
but I think for actually the
engineers and researchers,
we're good at seeing
these kinds of patterns.
We're working on these
kinds of patterns.
And not seeing them in the
world is no longer an option.
It's kind of like once your eyes
are open to it then you see it.
Although they are
sort of separate,
I think the people who get
the most inspired by it,
some of the people who
are the most driven,
are the people who are seeing
the patterns on both sides
of the coin, both in the machine
learned models world as well
as their everyday work life.
TIMNIT GEBRU: I was
also going to say,
one of the things I was thinking
about is many of the papers,
or the works when we are
talking about machine learning
and fairness, we don't look at
the data generation process.
I guess there is this Moritz's
paper on causality that
tries to look at, OK, how could
this data have been generated?
But most of the time
we just take the data
and we say, given this data,
what are our biases that exist,
and what notions of fairness
can we use and stuff.
And one direction--
I don't know how
to bring this in.
But one direction I
really want to think about
is, how can you
transfer the knowledge
that you have about
what types of biases
can exist to your model of
how this data could have been
generated, and therefore, in
what ways it could be biased,
so that maybe you
can have knobs.
Like if you had a crime
recidivism rate model, instead
of giving it to some judges
and it just spits out
a probability
saying, this person
has x likelihood of
committing a crime.
Maybe the judge-- if
someone had a tool
to say, OK, what if I know
that this particular data could
have been biased in
a particular way?
For example, this particular
zip code is x times more
heavily policed or
something like that.
What if I can have some knobs
and change what kinds of biases
could exist.
And then that kind of
tells me what the variance
could be for a
particular person,
like the person's outcome
or something like this.
I don't know.
And so in that case,
then your knowledge
of the world and society is
very, very useful, right?
And you could transfer
it directly to your work.
MELANIE WARRICK: Do
you think that there
are certain problems
that we should not
be solving right now with
machine learning, especially
based on the fact that we
have bias in our data, bias
in the way we're developing?
MARGARET MITCHELL:
I think what we
need to be really
careful to include
the experts and the people
who are really qualified
to work on different
problems, when we're thinking
about using machine learning.
And I can give us some
specific examples.
So one thing is when we
work on machine learning
in the clinical realm
or the health domain,
one of the issues that is really
difficult from a pure machine
learning perspective is how
to create technology that
is directly useful
for clinicians
and that also has some sort of
explainability for patients.
And how do you work with consent
around clinician and patient
if you're using machine
learning models?
And how exactly will
this be applied?
And one thing that's really
kind of struck me about this
is that we need to make
sure that as we work
on machine learning,
in light of diversity
and in light of inclusion,
include all the people who this
would be directly affecting
and who would potentially
be working with this in
order to understand what
the real problems are and
bring in the expertise
where we don't have it
as computer scientists.
I mean, machine learning
is super powerful,
and it's easy to get
into this thought process
where you feel like you
can sort of do anything,
like you're Superman
or something.
And that misses
the fact that there
are so many nuances
and so many details
across so many
different disciplines
that you're just
going to overlook,
when you're only focusing on
the machine learning hammer.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's
a great point considering
I know there's always
the question of, how
do you test these algorithms?
How do you fully test
these algorithms?
And that maybe not
fully, but definitely
looking at a broader way
to test the algorithms.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
TIMNIT GEBRU: I totally--
I always agree with Meg, but
I totally agree with this.
Because one example
was, I, was talking
to Adam Kalai about some idea
I was really excited about.
And we just went
on the whiteboard,
and we were writing
probabilities and things
like this.
And then Glenn, who's an
economist, is saying, well,
but the way it would
really work in the courts
is like someone would
sue someone like this.
And he just kind of
killed our idea like that.
But it was really interesting
to hear his perspective
because I had absolutely no idea
of what he was talking about
before.
But he explained it to me.
But unless you work
with people like that,
you're not going to
come up with something
that's directly applicable.
And you're not going to
come up with something that
actually addresses the problem.
You might come up with
a paper that's cool,
but I don't think you're going
to come up with something that
actually addresses the problem.
MARGARET MITCHELL: Right
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
This is super fascinating.
I'm also kind of
curious to hear,
also, you've
touched on it a bit,
like saying that we
don't always need to talk
about the technical side.
But I'd love to talk about the
technical side too and see,
is there solutions on the
software side of things
as well?
Or how you build your models,
or how you build your data sets?
Can you talk about that to see
if there is opportunity there
as well to help with biases?
MARGARET MITCHELL: Yeah.
There's definitely a lot to do.
We're not in a situation
where we have a silver bullet
or a clear solution.
But we do have a lot of
things that we can do.
For example, on the data
side, by including sources
that are not just those
that are the most easiest,
or most available to us,
and actually thinking
about sampling from
locations across the world,
different kind of
demographic categories,
making sure that what
we do is representative
of who we want to
serve and who we
want to work with as opposed
to what's at easy access.
And this is something
that requires
people who are good at
collecting data from people,
which might not be machine
learning scientists
necessarily, but might be a
whole other sort of section
of expertise.
But there's a lot to be done
on how to create inclusive data
sets, data sets that capture
a lot of different world
views, that aren't
necessarily going
to be downloadable
from Flickr or Twitter
doing some simple
query searches.
On the machine
learning side, there
is a lot of really interesting
work coming out now
in the space of bias mitigation.
It's also kind of called
unbiasing or de-biasing,
which is an oversell.
That's a bit of hype.
What we're actually doing when
we work with these models is,
we take a look at some sort
of known biases, some known
stereotypes.
For example, Timnit
mentioned the Kalai work,
associating woman to homemaker
while associating man
to computer programmer.
These are these kinds of biases
that we can kind of discover
and then build models
around in order to define
what is this subspace of bias?
What is this subspace of
gender bias, for example?
And can we do some cool
math to address it,
doing something like
subtracting it out
from our representations?
I've been doing some fun
work at Google, where
we do adversarial predictions.
We basically take predictions
on some sensitive attribute
and then negate the gradient
that we get from that in order
to force the model to not be
able to make decisions based
on race, or based
on gender, or based
on different kinds of
sensitive characteristics.
There's a lot that is coming out
and can be done on the ML side.
There's a lot more to do.
And I'd love to see a lot
more focus on the data side.
But these are just starts.
This is just the
start of something
that could be much bigger.
TIMNIT GEBRU: So one
thing I was thinking about
is that we talk
about certain things
like, for example, I gave the
example of this open CD library
not detecting Joy's face, right?
So a lot of times we talk about
diversifying our data sets.
So even with our paper with Joy,
we have this diverse data set,
more diverse data set, so people
can test out their algorithms.
But you know, humans.
As a human, if I've never seen--
is this true?
Like, if I've never seen
a black person before
and I see a black person
for the first time,
I would identify them as
a black person, right?
I mean, as a person.
Like I wouldn't just
not detect their face.
Or someone, if I see a
new race of some people
and given all of the data
that I've seen before not
being from that race.
So I feel like maybe there's
an opportunity for us
to go farther than just
purely supervised machine
learning, where if you don't
see it in your data set then
it's not accurate.
And in order to make
it more accurate
you need to diversify
your data set.
I feel like it
could help us have
a paradigm shift
in how we approach
these types of problems.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And I know there's
the value of using these models,
especially to think of new ways
to solve problems or think of
new ways to think about things.
That's the real value add
that several of these models
have come about,
which is touching
on what you're
talking about, like
this unstructured learning.
We try not to tell
the model what
to think and try not to
influence what the model should
be thinking.
We should try to let
it discover on its own.
But I know the biggest challenge
is with the data to begin with.
Do you think that
there's still a way
to fully pull out
the bias, especially
when you are working with
predictive models that
are doing something that's
in relation to people?
TIMNIT GEBRU: So
one thing that's
interesting is that if we
pick the attribute, what
we call sensitive
attributes or, I don't know,
protected classes, right, so
race, gender, age, disability,
sexuality, religion, et cetera,
et cetera, et cetera, then
I think we have a
better chance because we
can see what the disparities
could be with those things.
But when you look at
things like health care,
when you move into a
broader view of things,
these are not going
to be the only things
that you will have systematic
bias in, in my opinion.
And so then the
question will be,
I think also, how could we
discover the bias that we
might not already know exists?
So even in the work that Meg
mentioned, they already knew.
Like, they kind of guessed
that there would be bias,
like a gender based bias.
So what about other attributes
that we haven't thought about?
Because we're not 100% diverse.
Even if you're
well-meaning, there
is going to be a bias that
you not aware of unless you're
interacting with somebody
from that part of the world.
So how do we also
address those issues?
I don't really have
the answer to that.
But yeah, that's a question
I'm thinking about.
MELANIE WARRICK: You have
to have all the answers.
MARGARET MITCHELL:
One thing, one thing
that is really useful, I'm
going to put a plug here
for this in case there
are machine learning
people listening.
One thing that is
really useful to do
is to take a look at
your false positive rate
and false negative rate.
And false negative rate is
one minus true positive rate,
so this is this kind of thing
you get from an ROC curve.
I think in both MLP
and computer vision
there tends to be a focus
on precision recall.
In MLP, F score is big.
In vision, accuracy is big.
This overlooks the
kinds of errors
that might
disproportionally affect
different kinds of subgroups,
different kinds of groups
of people.
And so by having
some focus, at least
in our classification systems,
on what the differences
are in the false negative
rate and false positive rate,
can give us a sense of how these
things might be underperforming
when we do intersectional
analyses by subgroup.
That doesn't say
much about score
based systems or
ranking based systems,
but there is some
basic things that we
can do with our given machine
learning and statistics
machinery to focus in on some
sort of statistical version
of disparate impact,
or how things
might be affecting some
subgroups worse than others.
TIMNIT GEBRU: In
our current paper
we were analyzing APIs, right?
So the APIs were
gender classification.
So they just look at a
face and they give you
a binary male/female label.
And they don't give you
a probability or anything
like that.
They just give the label.
And this does not
allow you to adjust.
For your particular
setting, you might
want to have different types of
false positive, false negative
rates.
And if you don't get
the probability output,
you don't have a
chance to adjust this.
MARGARET MITCHELL:
The thresholds, yeah.
TIMNIT GEBRU: The
threshold, exactly.
So this is one concrete
step that commercial APIs
can take because
I'm certainly very
worried about commercial
APIs, because at least,
OK, in research you have
an understanding that it's
research.
Maybe it's for only the
research community, et cetera.
These commercial APIs are being
used by so many different start
ups, so many different
people, and we don't know.
We don't have any regulation.
MARGARET MITCHELL:
Potentially governments.
TIMNIT GEBRU: Governments
could use them.
We don't have-- they're
not accountable.
They don't have to
tell us what they're
using, what the
accuracy is, what
the characteristics of
the software is for what,
for which reasons.
So I guess I'm bringing it back
to the standardization stuff,
but I think this is--
Meg's example is a great
example of, I think,
the kinds of information,
additional information,
that these APIs need to give us.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
interpretability, I
know that's a huge one too,
in terms of understanding
what's really going on inside
of the model to begin with.
And Mark, I want to make
sure you have a chance.
I know you had another
question you wanted to ask.
MARK MANDEL: No, no, no.
You're good.
Keep going.
MELANIE WARRICK:
OK, well I think
that one of the
other questions--
and you both have
touched on this
already is, what are some of
the other tools in the space
that you'd recommend
that people can use now
to help with their
own work in machine
learning and driving fairness?
MARGARET MITCHELL:
So on my side I
can speak to some Google
products and services
that I'm actually
kind of excited about
and have been
working with a bit.
So one thing is Facets, which
is a visualization for ML data
sets.
It's available on GitHub.
And it's a way that you
can do different slicing
across different kinds
of groups, or subgroups,
or demographic
characteristics, in order
to see how well your
data, or how well
your output, is representing
each of these different kinds
of groups.
It's a really handy
visualization tool.
And you can look at the effect
of different thresholding
and do a lot of really
cool stuff with it.
So that's something
that Google has put out
to help on the data
side of understanding
some of the possible biases.
There's also this
thing that's come out
from Google called
Lattice, which
helps with some kind
of post-op analyses
and interpretability about
different machine learning
models.
I believe it's publicly
called Lattice.
Google-- yes,
Tensor Flow Lattice.
And we're putting more
and more into TensorFlow
to help with different
kinds of machine
learning problems that can
deal with fairness and bias.
We're kind of keeping it really
technically focused right now
but creating this
code base that we
can share with others to
help with these kinds of bias
and fairness issues.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
Timnit, what about you?
TIMNIT GEBRU: Oh I would
recommend that people check out
the FAT* conference
that's about to happen.
And the tutorial section
has a whole bunch
of tools like just software
to visualize your data
and what kind of
discrimination might exist
to pre-process some
data, some tools
to help with interpretability.
So really I think a
lot of the tutorial
is just about these
different tools.
So I would just recommend
that people check those out.
MARGARET MITCHELL: Joy
is totally using Facets
by the way, Timnit.
I don't know if you know that.
But for all of her
beautiful visualizations,
totally using Facets.
I'm like, dude, that's the tool!
MARK MANDEL: I'll
jump here real quick.
You've mentioned Joy twice.
Do you want to talk a
little bit about what
that is, because I
think we talked about it
before the actual
podcast started.
TIMNIT GEBRU: Joy is
as person, a person who
is a bundle of joy.
MARK MANDEL: There we go.
MARGARET MITCHELL:
She's a person.
TIMNIT GEBRU: --and energy.
MARGARET MITCHELL:
She's a mutual friend.
TIMNIT GEBRU: She's a
bundle of joy and energy.
Joy is a student
at MIT Media Lab,
who focuses on face recognition
and bias in face recognition.
And I consider her--
I mean, at this point she's
a computer vision person.
She keeps on saying
that she's not, but--
MARGARET MITCHELL: Her
name is Joy Buolamwini.
We should say her--
TIMNIT GEBRU: She has something
called the Algorithmic Justice
League.
She even gave a TED talk.
MARK MANDEL: Did she?
Awesome.
TIMNIT GEBRU: And she
just started her PhD.
And I met her two
years ago, ish.
And we've been
collaborating ever since.
So our current paper at FAT*
is actually based on her
master's thesis.
So she sent a
whole bunch of time
analyzing face
recognition, and she did
this intersectional analysis.
So usually people just look at--
well, usually people just
look at aggregate accuracy
on some sort of data set.
And then maybe they
would break it down
by male, female, or race.
And so she said,
OK, you can't just
break it down by just gender,
or just race, or just age.
You have to look at the
intersection of gender or race,
or gender, race and age,
et cetera, et cetera.
And then she also thought,
people have done this analysis
across different racial groups.
But race, as we know, is
a very unstable category.
So what is considered
black in the US is
very different from
Brazil, from South Africa,
from Ethiopia, et cetera.
And it's not even
stable across time.
So her idea was to use
this more objective
metric of skin tone, what's
called a Fitzpatrick skin
classification system,
and so analyze accuracy
by the intersection
of gender and that.
And also other things
too, but for this paper it
was just gender.
And so Joy has been
very vocal about this.
She's been working with various
organizations like the IEEE
to come up with a new standard.
But in addition
to that, she also
works on just
algorithmic fairness.
From the social standpoint
and from a technical stand--
I mean, she does so many
things I can't keep track
of all the things she's doing.
She also makes short movies.
And she also raps, by the way.
I was just--
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
MARGARET MITCHELL:
She's super inspiring.
TIMNIT GEBRU: Again,
diversity, for me come in,
because people like her are
generally either turned away
from the field of machine
learning or somehow weeded out.
MARGARET MITCHELL: Yeah.
TIMNIT GEBRU: I think
that type of personality
is generally given some
sort of subliminal message
that they don't belong
in this environment.
And we really need to change
the educational system
or the marketing or whatever
it is that is excluding people
like her to bring
in people like her
because we absolutely
need those types of people
in this field, especially when
we're talking about fairness.
MARGARET MITCHELL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Completely agree.
MARGARET MITCHELL:
Just be clear.
So her last name Buolamwini.
And you can check out
her TED talk if you want,
which covers a lot of this.
The last name is spelled
B-U-O-L-A-M-W-I-N-I.
MARK MANDEL: We'll put a
link in the show notes.
MARGARET MITCHELL:
Awesome, awesome, yeah.
TIMNIT GEBRU: Yeah.
Also, ajlunited.org is the
Algorithmic Justice League.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Great, thank you.
And I also wanted to make sure,
Timnit, can you also tell us,
because I know
you touched on it.
But can you explain a
little bit more about FAT*?
I know this is a
conference that you're one
of the ones who's founded it?
TIMNIT GEBRU: No, I'm in
the program committee,
and so is Meg.
MELANIE WARRICK: OK.
TIMNIT GEBRU: But the person
who-- well, the main people
are Sorelle Friedler,
Suresh, and Solon Barocas.
So if you go fatconference.org--
I'm just a big fan.
I always talk about it.
I don't want people to think
that I founded this conference.
MELANIE WARRICK: No worries.
TIMNIT GEBRU: But if you
go to fatconference.org,
you'll see who the editors are
and who the program chair is
and things like this.
MARGARET MITCHELL: Yeah,
so this was actually
started as a workshop at NIPS,
which is a top deep learning
conference.
I believe Solon
Barocas and Moritz
Hardt were the original sort
of creators a few years back.
And that was before it
was super hot, super hip
to look at diversity and policy
and these kinds of issues.
They were really interested
in combining machine learning
and law, things like taking
the Civil Rights Act from 1964
and its notion of
disparate impact
and then applying
that mathematically
to something like
demographic parity,
and so really making
those connections
between the legal world and
the ML mathematical world.
And it's really gotten
tons of interest
and really started making
some strides in this space.
And so now it's become
its own conference.
And it switched from FAT/ML
to FAT* as a kind of nod
to regular expressions.
So its Fairness, Accountability,
and Transparency, not
just for machine learning
but for lots of other things
as well.
TIMNIT GEBRU: You know what?
What I'm excited
about this conference
is the fact that it's
interdisciplinary.
Again, I am a huge fan of
interdisciplinary teams
in general.
And one of the things
that I haven't seen before
is in its tutorials
they have also
these translational
tutorials, so
these specifically
translational tutorials, which
could be translating a concept
that is very well known
in one specific area to people
from a different specific area.
So it could be translating
a very well known machine
learning concept to
lawyers, or translating
very well-known
things in health care
to machine learning
people, so just
kind of bridging
this gap of knowledge
between the different
groups so that we
can have some common
understanding and common ground
to start working together.
MELANIE WARRICK: This is great.
And I hate to say it, that
were pretty much close to time
because we could talk--
TIMNIT GEBRU: Oh, wow!
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: We could about
this for a while, clearly--
clearly.
I did want to ask you both, as
we get close to wrapping this
out, is there any
last things that you
wanted to talk about
in terms of making
sure people are aware of?
Anything you wanted to plug?
Margaret, do you have
anything that comes to mind?
MARGARET MITCHELL:
Right, so if people
are interested in
this space, it's
not just fairness that
is sort of interest,
I think, to people
working on fairness.
Its ethics, broadly.
And so there are also ethics
conferences to be aware of.
There was just one that was
co-located with AAAI, The AI,
Ethics, and Society Conference.
Coming up, I'm hosting one for
NLP for language processing
specifically, Ethics in Natural
Language Processing, which will
be in New Orleans on June 5th.
So there's lots of other
ways to get involved
if you'd like to
take a look at ethics
broadly with machine learning.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Right, thank you.
Timnit?
TIMNIT GEBRU: Yeah, I want
to say something about hype,
and ethics, and fairness.
I think that we should
all care about fairness,
and ethics, and
diversity, of course.
But sometimes all of these
words are used as buzzwords.
And sometimes they're
used for PR purposes.
used for image purposes.
So let me give an
example, if you
have an all-male panel on AI
for Ethics or AI for Social Good
or something like this,
I have very little faith
that this is actually
AI for Social Good.
If you have an all-male team,
or a very homogeneous team,
or you've never graduated a
female student, or something
like this, and now people
are talking about AI ethics
and things like that.
So I think people say charity
starts at home, right?
So I encourage
everybody to think
about our local,
our surroundings,
and think about AI
ethics in that sense
because it's not just like
raising money or creating
the next coolest fairness
kind of algorithm.
It's also about including people
who are very well positioned
to work on these problems
in your surroundings,
in your immediate surroundings.
MARGARET MITCHELL: Yeah, one
thing I'd like to look at
is how many papers have
been published with women?
Like what is your track record
for publishing with women?
What is your track record for
producing projects with women?
This is one of these things that
gets overlooked but can also
be a sign of a lack of
understanding or inclusion
of these kinds of
other viewpoints.
TIMNIT GEBRU: Yeah,
and so this is
why I'm always so happy
that Meg is always
talking about
accessibility as well
as part of the conversation
around ethics, for example.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
I wish we had more
time, I really do.
This has been a remarkable,
remarkable conversation
and I really thank you
so much to both of you,
Timnit and Margaret--
TIMNIT GEBRU: Thank you.
MARGARET MITCHELL:
Yeah, thank you.
MARK MANDEL: --for joining us.
I really appreciate it.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Thank you very much.
MARK MANDEL: Maybe we'll
just have to do this again
at some point soon.
MARGARET MITCHELL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
Have to do a part two.
MARGARET MITCHELL:
And any chance
where I get to talk to Timnit,
I'm really happy with her.
MELANIE WARRICK: Next
time we'll get Joy.
TIMNIT GEBRU: Yeah, yeah.
MARGARET MITCHELL:
Yeah, that's good.
She's missing.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
Well, again, thank you
so much for joining us.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank
you, Timnit and Margaret,
again for that great interview.
I really wish we'd had
more time with them
because it was a good topic.
It's an important topic.
And it's something
that we can explore
in more detail in many ways.
As Timnit had mentioned
and Margaret had mentioned,
FAT* is this conference
that's coming up next week.
And actually over
the weekend there
was some great press
and coverage for a paper
that both Joy and
Timnit had worked
on that's titled, "Gender
Shades, Intersectional
Accuracy Disparities
in Commercial Gender
Classification." and they
do this basically assessment
of facial recognition systems
and how good they are,
in essence, of being able
to recognize, especially
from a shade and
gender perspective.
And they use some interesting
techniques to assess that.
So we'll include that in our
show notes in terms of links
to that and all the
links to all the things
that were referenced while
we were talking to them.
Good stuff.
So Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
MELANIE WARRICK: Got to
ask you this question.
Question of the week, right?
It's always got to get a
good question in there.
How do you feel?
No, our question of the
week is, as I mentioned,
you had this wonderful
chat with KF.
MARK MANDEL: Any chat
with KF is wonderful.
MELANIE WARRICK:
It's all on Twitter.
But you both were
talking about, is there
a GCP service that handles
Cloud Identity-Aware
Proxy, especially host
via cloud storage?
So, Mark, is there?
MARK MANDEL: Is there?
OK, so if people aren't aware
of Cloud Identity-Aware Proxy,
it's a proxy that you can put
in front of your applications
that controls whether
people have access,
basically, through
their account logins.
It works with App Engine
standard, App Engine
flexible environment, Compute
Engine, and Kubernetes engine.
But what KF wants
to do is put it
in front of Google Cloud
Storage for static sides.
So the short answer
is, unfortunately, no.
But there are a couple of
interesting workarounds
that I think are
worth discussing.
The first one is, and it's
a bit of a cheeky answer,
but you can always host static
content on App Engine itself.
There's no reason why not.
It's actually really,
really easy to do.
There's a lot of
opportunities there
for putting static content.
And if you're using some
sort of programming language
and you wanted to mix
and match, there's
also opportunities to do
stuff like that as well.
So that's always a thing.
So you could always
put the static content,
rather than putting it
in Google Cloud Storage,
you can put it on App Engine and
then put Cloud Identity-Aware
Proxy in front of
that, and you still
get a lot of the really
great edge caching you would
get on Google Cloud Storage.
The other option is
a open-source product
that's available on
GitHub, and we'll
have the links in
the show notes.
It's called Weasel, which
is an interesting name
in and of itself, which
is basically an App Engine
proxy for basically files
that you store on Google Cloud
Storage.
So you could put this
up on App Engine,
then just change whatever
you need to change or host
whatever you need to host
inside Google Cloud Storage,
and then put the Identity-Aware
Proxy in front of that data
application that
runs on App Engine.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
it's called Weasel?
MARK MANDEL: It's called Weasel.
Yeah, I--
MELANIE WARRICK: Great name.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I don't know.
I don't know.
It's a thing.
I'm going to assume the
naming has something
to do with it's like a--
weasels make tunnels and it's
like tunneling through from App
Engine to Cloud Storage.
That's my theory.
MELANIE WARRICK: Sure,
we'll go with that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I
genuinely don't know.
But those are the two options.
Neither is exactly
what KF is looking
for but it does give
you some options
to allow you to do
something similar to what
it is you're looking to do.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
Yeah, I know.
She was definitely like well,
that's not really what I want,
but hey.
We're trying to help.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
MELANIE WARRICK:
OK, so, Mark, where
are you going to be in
the next couple of weeks?
MARK MANDEL: Still
doing all the work
that I can possibly for GDC.
I'm pretty excited about that.
MELANIE WARRICK: Is GDC a thing?
MARK MANDEL: GDC is a thing.
I'll start talking a
bit more about that.
But yeah, we'll be
having a booth presence
across Google on the floor.
So I'll be giving talks there.
There's some other fun stuff
we're also organizing as well.
So as we get a bit closer
and everything gets
super locked down--
MELANIE WARRICK:
Lots of preparation.
MARK MANDEL: Lots
of preparation.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: What
are you up you?
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm going to go
to New York for FAT* next week.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: And that's
where you will be finding me.
But outside of that, I think
that covers us for this week.
MARK MANDEL: All right.
Well, Melanie, thank you
for joining me once again
on the episode this week.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thanks, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: And thank
you all for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]